I think there's two things that I've
really seen in my perspective,
the Internet changing,
one is who's using it and to how it's
being used.
You know,
I went to school at Uc Santa Cruz right
when the Internet was really being
developed and I can remember doing my,
you know,
my coding,
my das coding and I was on computers
land.
It was a very impersonal,
um,
medium.
Um,
and then websites came where you went to
the website and you got information and
maybe you did ecommerce.
But what's really changed about the
Internet now it's become much more of an
intimate of tool.
It's about for many people it's about
their life.
It's about we go on Amazon,
it's about the books that they might
like,
you know,
what's recommended.
They're reading the reviews that they're
their friends or even strangers instead
of just advertisement.
So the whole Internet has become,
with facebook,
with my space is become much more of an
intimate and personal thing.
And because of that,
I think that the dynamics and who is
using it have really changed.
I think it started off as sort of a
white male,
sort of a geeky tool and now actually
more women are online.
The men are more women are blogging than
men are women.
It's really a women's a medium.
If you think about it.
I mean we are through our brain
chemistry.
We're wired to be connected to other
people and the Internet is such a
powerful way to connect whether it's
through,
you know,
my space or I'm a facebook or twitter,
I think a lot of these things are going
to come and go.
I think twitter will come and then you
know,
who knows?
There might be a new version of twitter
that technology may change,
but the truth is is that people are
gaining relationships in new ways than
they ever have been.
Like I can talk to someone in Ghana
about a problem with genital mutilation
that I never was before.
So it's become much more of an intimate
tool.
It's changed politics.
What's interesting now with Intel,
Andy Grove is always poking holes in his
company to try to find out,
you know,
whereas competitors are going to come in
and take them out all at one time was
the breakthrough technology and then all
of a sudden aol is sort of an old story
in the new stories,
facebook and sort of what will be next
after that.
There's so much.
The convergence between the web and
television is completely is what's next.
You know,
every,
almost every household has a television.
It's part of our lives.
It's part of our identity and that
intimacy that we see both through the
Internet and also what people are
enjoying watching.
People love American idol because it's
an intimate show.
They're seeing people like themselves
reflecting.
So I'm not sure exactly where it's
going,
but I know we're going to continue to
have user generated content.
I think people are going to be booking,
they're creating their own television
shows.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
um,
there's going to be much more instant
response to the way that television
works and we're just going to see a
convergence.